نتحول الان الى العمليات العسكريه في قطاع
غزه وهذا الخبر نقلا عن كتائب القسام التي
تقول انها فجرت عبوه مضاده للافراد في قوه
صهيونيه
متوغل في خزاعه شرق خانيونس وانها اسقطت
افرادها بين قتيل
وجريح اذا هذا الخبر نقلا عن كتائب القسام
وكانت اذا الاخبار تتوالى هذه الاخبار
الاخيره التي تفيد اذا بتفجير عبوه مضاده
للافراد في قوه صهيونيه متوغلا في خزعه
وكانت كتائب القسام قالت ايضا انها تدك
تجمعات عده لجنود واليات العدو شرق مدينه
خان يونس في جنوب القطاع بقذائف الهون
كذلك ذلك
اكدت او قالت القسام انها استهدفت 15 اليه
في قطاع غزه منها دبابه ميركافا بقذائف
الياسين 105 جنوب الشرق مخيم البريج وسط
القطاع وخمس دبابات الشرق خان يونس جنوب
القطاع وذكرت ان مقاتليها استهدفوا دبابه
اخرى بعبوه شواظ شرق البريج كما استهدفت
في المخيم نفسه جرافه اسرائيليه بقذيفه
الياسين 105 وقالت الكتائب ان مقاتليها
استهدفوا دبابه صهيونيه اخرى بقذيفه
الياسين 105 شرق مخيم المغازي وسط القطاع
مما ادى الى احداث انفجارات
بداخلها اما في مدينه غزه فقالت الكتائب
انها استهدفت سبع اليات عسكريه بقذائف
الياسين 105 وعبوات شواظ في منطقتي التفاح
والدرج m